entre le chef de l'état et son armée
tout a commencé par une crise
rappelez vous le 12 juillet 2017 soit
moins de deux mois après l'élection d'
emmanuel macron le chef d'état-major des
armées pierre de villiers réagi plutôt
mal aux coupes de 850 millions d'euros
dans son budget annoncé deux jours plus
tôt le grand écart entre les objectifs
assignés à nos forces et des moyens
alloués n'est plus tenable
je ne me laisserai pas comme ça des mots
fleuris qui arrive aux oreilles des
manuels macron qui le lendemain au
ministère des armées hôtel de brienne
procède à un sérieux recadrage public
je suis votre chef les engagements que
je prends devant nos concitoyens et
devant les armées je sais les tenir et
je n'ai à cet égard besoin de nulle
pression et deux nuls commentaire une
humiliation pour le général cinq étoiles
présents ce jour là et qui le lendemain
le 14 juillet ronge son frein pendant le
défilé aux côtés du président quelques
jours plus tard le grade et présente sa
démission une première dans l'histoire
de la vème république et quitte ses
bureaux sous une haie d'honneur et
d'applaudissements nourris
ce qui ne manque pas de faire tiquer
l'elysée alors cet épisode n'aura pas
augurer de l'état global des relations
entre macron et son armée les budgets de
la défense ont bien fini par augmenter
comme jamais d'ailleurs depuis quatre
décennies 198 milliards d'euros de
crédits prévus entre 2019 et 2023 1,7
milliard d'euros de plus par an pour un
budget de 1021 de 39,2 milliards d'euros
soit près de 20% de plus qu'en 2017 et
un objectif de 2% du pib consacré à la
défense en 2025 de quoi satisfaire
l'armée qui peut enfin augmenter ses
moyens en effectif comme en équipement
et puis emmanuel macron a multiplié les
attentions à l'égard des militaires
comme au cours des dernières années
comme cet hommage national à cédric de
pierrepont et alain berton selo tués
pendant une opération de récupération
d'otages au burkina faso où l'unique
cérémonie de voeux présidentiels de 2019
réservé à des militaires restent tout de
même la tribune publiée dans valeurs
actuelles en avril dernier et signée par
deux noms
militaires dont une vingtaine de
généraux en retraite du service actif et
qui dénonce un délitement du pays et en
appelle à un sursaut les périls montrent
la violence s'accroît de jour en jour
nous serviteur de la nation ne pouvons
être devant de tels agissements des
spectateurs passifs
nous sommes disposés à soutenir les
politiques qui prendront en
considération la sauvegarde de la nation
il n'est plus temps de tergiverser
sinon demain la guerre civile mettra un
terme à ce chaos croissant et les morts
dont vous porterez la responsabilité se
compteront par milliers et puis il ya ce
départ annoncé il ya un mois du général
françois lecointre le successeur de
pierre de villiers à la tête de l'état
major des armées
l'actuel cema a souhaité quitter son
poste avant la fin du mandat d' emmanuel
macron afin de protéger la fonction
la première raison est d'éviter qu'il y
ait une politisation de la fonction de
chef d'état major des armées
je ne souhaitais pas qu'un chef d'état
major des armées qui est un chef
militaire soit associée à un politique
je pense qu'il est bon que les deux
calendriers soient dissociées il faut
surtout éviter qu'on imagine qu'un chef
d'état major des armées soit choisi pour
ses opinions politiques
le militaire redoute par ailleurs le
retour de conflit de haute intensité
comme dans le haut-karabagh à l'automne
dernier et regrettent des moyens
militaires insuffisant pour y faire face
la loi de programmation militaire ne
vise pas une montée en puissance ou
l'acquisition d'une masse qui
permettrait à l'armée de s'engager dans
un conflit étatique majeur alors
relativisons emmanuel macron n'est pas
le seul président à avoir eu maille à
partir avec son armée en 88 plusieurs
anciens chefs d'état major avait publié
un pamphlet contre françois mitterrand
quelques jours avant l'élection
présidentielle et même le très respecté
de gaulle avait dû essuyer un putsch des
généraux
il y à 60 ans reste qu emmanuel macron
aura eu fort à faire pour préserver les
liens avec la grande muette